Chuck is with us to start off this hour
in Arlington Virginia hi Chuck how are
you Dave I'm great how are you better
than I deserve what's up
awesome Happy New Year I'm recently
engaged to my girlfriend thank you I did
pay for the ring in cash but when you
have America plans are early 2020
still working on a date good and hoping
to pay for the wedding in cash as well
but my main question is in regards to
buying a house obviously with getting
recently engaged or starting to have
conversations about a house sure obvious
Northern Virginia area how this can be
pretty expensive yeah but so just wanted
it as we're looking just wanted to kind
of get your advice your expert advice on
are we ready to purchase a home and how
much well I know how much home we should
buy but how to find a home in you know
that is no more than 25% of our
take-home pay in this area okay
well the magic to that is you might not
be in that area you may be driving you
may increase your commute generally
speaking if you drop a pebble in the
center of a major metro area in the
Rings like on a pond when you drop a
pebble in a pond the rings that go out
generally speaking the further you go
out from the central business district
the cheaper gets now in your particular
area you've got several metro areas that
are overlapping from from DC to
Baltimore to you know Arlington in and
of itself and so on and so it's not
quite as clean as perfectly concentric
rings but generally speaking the further
you get out of town things are cheaper
unless you land on a mountain or buy
some water or into the most expensive
area in the world which is possible so
all that to say is I don't know you do
not get a pass on math based on the fact
you live in an expensive area you still
have to pay wise so that's thing one
thing to then is of course you probably
it sounds like you've listened to as
enough to know that I'm going to tell
you to not buy a home until you're
debt-free have your emergency fund flush
your down payment you know that part
right that's correct yeah enough I am
debt free I've got about 80 K in savings
55 K is for the down payment on the
house
16 caves in the emergency parts very
calm and how much how much does she have
she said we haven't combined our on oh
you shouldn't you shouldn't yeah yeah
you should know right so she's got about
5 K oh no okay
save towards the down payment Oh does
she have any debt no dad no one of us
had that Wow old are you - I'm 34 and
she's 31 okay alright okay yeah I think
you just pile up money for the wedding
and the rest of it use the rest of the
pile that you pile up between now and
wedding date is your down payment on
your home I think it's okay to go slow
buying a home there is no federal law
that says get married and buy a house
the next month and the generally
speaking if you were 10 years younger I
would give you a 20-minute speech not
really but I would really push you hard
to wait a year to buy you two are a
little bit more mature getting married
and so maybe not a whole year but it
takes a year of living together being
married to know how close to your
mother-in-law to buy the house and don't
know we I mean curtain rods you got a
hang and all the stuff you're gonna
fight about you just get to know each
other better after a year and you'll
make a better together decision after a
period of time so I wouldn't you know I
know I wouldn't buy a house in your
situation if you got married in January
of 2020 I wouldn't buy a house before
summer now we have lived together that's
the one thing so we've gotten a little
bit of practice I think we're close I
really I just don't want to do something
stupid here just makes ourselves more
than I can afford
don't just don't don't buy more than you
can afford that's you know you know what
the limits are I would stick with 15% or
a 15-year fixed-rate where the payments
no more than 1/4 of your take-home pay
you can do this it's just real easy to
look when you look at nicer houses then
you can afford it's hard to go back to
the ones
you can afford and you know that doesn't
matter what the budget is I mean if
you're looking at two million-dollar
houses and you go looking for
million-dollar houses it'll screw up
your brain you know I mean anytime you
go do that and the same thing with a car
you go look at a car you can't afford
then you got to go that cheaper version
it's like town man I wish you'd have
that heads up on there man you know we
should add that you use all that stuff
so you just got to avoid that so hey hey
man you're gonna do I you're gonna do
good you gonna be all right hey thanks
for the call